[Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  for justice  Tuesday at shootaround today  [Music]  [Music]  today nothing run before that  the bench London pilot way to the red  post the colors for Luke adoption  [Music]  [Music]  for points  spend move but they shall not good to go  down in rebuilds his own miss he's gonna  go fit three flowers also two points  three assists and three her to get into  three the lordly for the rookie look at  object Daanish oh yeah we like that  off balance lock situation here you go  [Music]  paint a few outside toluca that sweet  sound of the string music for Luca  dodging down to the tune of Ynez a key  part  [Music]  the three-point line Luca through  traffic went to the corner same spot  where Luca made one  you said it the matador the harder it is  the easier he makes it look  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  defensively  [Music]  you